haiti's most powerful gang leader says
the prime minister must resign
peacefully or armed militants will
remove him
jimmy charizae known throughout haiti by
his nickname barbecue made his threat in
a letter to the u.s ambassador asking
for american support
charizae leads a group of gangs known as
the g9 he read the letter to reporters
at a news conference surrounded by armed
men
at the cost of blood we are going to
dislodge mr al ali from the prime
minister's office and afterward the key
to the country will be handed over to a
new classes of men and women of civil
society who will have to govern
responsibly to get the country out of
the greg mar and which it has been stuck
for many ages
although charizae is one of haiti's most
wanted men the country's outgunned
police force made no effort to intervene
the man known as barbecue might be the
head of nine gangs but he says he isn't
a gangster he's not a politician he is
the leader of a political movement that
has launched a revolution here in the
streets of the western hemisphere's
poorest country we asked the prime
minister's office for a response and
they told al jazeera prime minister
ariel henry doesn't deal with gangs
charizae says haiti is dominated by an
elite five percent that he calls the
real gangsters he says he wants to turn
haiti into a u.s style liberal democracy
far from terrorizing the populations we
are fighting to get haiti out of the
yoke of a systematic poverty founded on
the basis of a plot between traditional
politicians and this corrupt
rotten
perverted bourgeoisie
more than 200 haitians deported from the
u.s and cuba returned on wednesday to a
capital in crisis
my life was in danger so i fled
now they sent me back i ran from hell
and now i am back
if anything haiti's condition has
worsened its economy crippled by a fuel
shortage its streets ruled by gangs its
government under threat john hendren al
jazeera port-au-prince